[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
versus I have a bag that I found that I
think belongs to Greta head tag
Oh bless your heart where did you find
it on the subway Oh would you like a cup
of coffee you've been so kind I don't
get many visitors here I've been so
lonely since my daughter left well I
could help you
my mom actually used to say I'm like
chewing though yes I didn't stick around
[Music]
the candles did you find them
I guess she's been planning bags around
the city hoping someone brings them back
to her and you did oh my god is her just
let it ring I saw the bags better I
never want to see you again
she's really freaking me out this is not
a problem
public area or rights are protected why
are you doing this how exciting
hi I'm Francis la vie our waitress for
the evening no I can't do this
are you a child whom you the child you
need a mother to hold you don't you dare
talk to me about my mother everyone
needs a friend
between more than friends
we're connected
there's something you need to know about
Greta are you insane
just try to get little beretta
you